the vanishment of innovation and product
development track is a track within the
within the business school that allows
students to take courses in design
engineering with a focus on marketing
and organizational behavior within the
business school when they go into the
workplace they'll have an advanced
knowledge of how to collaborate across
these disciplines and work in an
integrated fashion people say engineers
work different than MBAs and desires
work different than MBAs and they do but
you don't realize how different they
think until you work with them the
companies have patented products that
have come out of the course it's been
very successful and really a great
example of what can happen when you
bring together bright minds from
different disciplines
you